necessarily apologize to you man uh
forever if for making you feel some kind
of way uh uh and you know for any
discomfort I may have caused you uh
during our tenure together uh over on
mad and uh thank you for allowing me to
finally come here so we can hash this
out and we could you know uh make
everything right man you know some
Jackie Chan Chris Tucker [__] I love it
maybe we could do Rush Hour four if
Chris falls out of place
yeah okay it looks really nice your turn
you know I'll can I say this when you
walked in here I did not recognize you
it wasn't just your way there's
something just about your energy okay
that's completely I don't know what you
did Landmark forums you know live spring
or something you write a book or
something but I've been rehearsing this
for two weeks man
pretty good dude you memorized that yeah
yeah yeah so and you know and I accept
that right and you know honestly I don't
I don't have a problem it's just that I
like talking [__] it's how I make a
living right so I just say things and it
backfires we're going to run into people
and stuff so but I really don't never
really had an issue so that's well let
me just say uh here's the issue that I
had yeah yeah let's go let's go I forget
what station it was but it was like whoa
[__] what was that it's fine oh it was
like a gay radio station in San
Francisco that anytime I would do cobs I
used to go to pretty uh often to promote
the shows hadn't been there and God
knows how long but yeah I saw the clip
where you were talking to these guys and
it sounded like for the most part you
were being complimentary but at the same
time it felt obvious you were taking a
shot at me and I was going in my mind
I'm like why is he doing that like why
why is he going there um and then I
think through the grapevine as time went
on
you there were moments where I think you
elaborated even further as to why we had
such a you know relationship over it mad
uh and and as we hash this out I'm gonna
wait for you to say what I think you're
gonna say and then I'm going to tell you
why
I responded to you in that way or why it
may have been that way at the time
are you referring to the last time we
saw each other or during my activities
this Mad TV but why don't you tell me
what it is because you said earlier that
you said you had a problem what the
issue was tell me what the issue was
okay
where do I begin I remember
one thing you said you specifically was
yeah I never talked to you
you said Aries never talk to me can I
just let me get it out okay right let me
get it out and let and then let me um
and it's not a lot okay it's like 15th
no I'm kidding it's no it's not a lot
it's a couple of things all right
and this is my honest feeling okay
um
so when I like do you remember when I
was on Mad how terrible I was at table
read that's one of my biggest issues yes
what do you mean go ahead yeah yeah so
um when I would do table reads I would
be so nervous because I'd never done one
before and I never really acted before I
did commercials right but I mean there
was so much pressure that every time I
would do a table read I was fine when I
was on set he's also dyslexic so like
reading stuff off of papers really
really hard for him so like but no one
knew that right right so I'd be at table
reads and I wouldn't sleep all night
because I would try to memorize it and
then once I was there at the network
thing and I saw all the [__] actors
the first couple of years it was rough
and I remember like going oh [__] like
it's so embarrassing I used to have PTSD
from them right so that so when I first
got on there I was scared table reads
were bad
um I you know I'll be honest with you I
got on it when
Alex was still there so you and you
Alex and Deborah were going through some
sort of law thing
it wasn't it didn't get to that point
right but you guys weren't talking yes
so there was like a civil war right
going on at Mad TV between Aries and
Deborah Wilson not between us me and
Deborah was like no no yeah together and
Alex at the time right right and it was
because of a um cool joke with the
fingers yes right I remember yeah right
I don't want to get into that what it is
but there's coals on the fingers and so
in my head I was like oh there's some
sort of thing going on and then I think
there was a thing I might be wrong
between David Salzman the owner of the
show and Alex as well about merchandise
or something so now I'm coming into a
show where there's a civil war right you
can feel it like whoa this is weird and
then no and also I'm terrible so people
don't think that I'm gonna lie just so
you know David salsman and Alex
Bornstein two Jews arguing over money
that's just I know it's not just picking
I know you said merchandise I was like
merchandise yeah yeah yeah yeah so um so
I come on and then that's going on in
the show right so people don't think I'm
Gonna Last right so why would anyone
need to be nice to me right and also
um I'm feeling the end I'm an energy guy
so I'm just feeling this weird [__]
energy on this show right so then I meet
Aries and just my just you know I just
think that you were very standoffish
I like the word aloof but go ahead okay
you're a Loof right and then um
and I we didn't even have a conversation
for a couple of years
right like two or three years I remember
because I I'll tell you how I remember
my third year when I saw you once like
the beginning of the Season you said hi
to me my third year and I remember it
going being going wow that's weird I
think you wrote it in your Journal I
think yeah I had a journal from back
then where I wrote like Harry spear said
hi to me today right this is like you're
it's just a story here on a TV show
together it's like strange to me right
so that's the number one thing and the
second thing is this
um then let me stop there because let me
address that listen let me address that
well you can't write it down all three
and then where I see people okay
all right uh here's here was my issue
with you from gate
and and later on you revealed to us more
so that you had it's like substance
abuse problems right okay one I didn't
know that uh had I known that I would
have taken that into account that being
said here was my my problem you know